[Applause]
hello everyone looking at you all here
today I'm reminded of how I felt
when I sat at the audience of an
accessibility talk myself a few years
back I remember feeling like this
accessibility thing that I didn't really
know too much about was probably this
really cool thing but I didn't really
know how it applied to me or to the
project that I was building at the time
I was building a mobile site and I kept
hearing about keyboard accessibility
it's like how does this apply to the
thing that I'm building so I felt there
was this huge gap between my product and
accessibility and looking back now that
I kind of work on this I'm kind of
embarrassed about having been there but
it's at the same time I like to fully
own having felt that way because it's
it's helped me appreciate just how easy
it is to feel that way there's no shame
in it and and yeah just the fact that
accessibility seems to be very far away
but it's not it's not really that far so
fast forward a few years I'm working at
the Financial Times we since last year
we were building the fastest greatest
new site in the industry we released it
about a year ago I was great
successfully braced replace an old
monolithic web site and we started
winning all these words and excelling in
performance and security basically every
metric that we had set our sights on we
were sending on so one day we decided to
look at accessibility maybe we were
excelling at this to kind of like by
magic but unlike performance and
security we'd never really put a
collective effort into accessibility so
to no surprise we weren't very good and
that since this talk is going to be all
about the lessons that we learned that
was really the first the very first one
feasibility doesn't just happen you have
to make it happen
my name is Laura Carvajal I'm Smith
developer at the Financial Times this is
an actual picture of our office in
London we are a magical place and we own
a rainbow you can see that for the for
the better part of 2017 I was the lead
of the accessibility team and today I
want to tell you about so the lessons
that we learned in the ft.com team once
realize we had built this beautiful
performance thing that really couldn't
be enjoyed by everyone so if today
you're in that place where you're
wondering if this whole thing applies to
your project hopefully today you'll walk
away convinced that it does and that
it's that it's very easy to do so what
is accessibility there are many
definitions out there you'll find but I
like this one very much because it
really strips it down to to its core
I'm gonna read out to you web
accessibility means that people with
disabilities can use the web that's it
it boils it down to making sure that
we're not denying access to anyone to
the thing that we're building but I want
to go a little bit deeper if you allow
me I want to tell you a quick story I
was in a shopping mall in London while
back and we were I was with my daughter
we were going up those escalators and
and she asked me how does someone in a
wheelchair do what we're doing and she's
she's only ten but she's very aware of
accessibility mostly because I practiced
my accessibility talks on her and she's
asked me this and I'm all proud and I
say oh there's a lift and as we were
going up there we she says well where is
it we really couldn't see it from there
once we got to the top with we saw that
at the very at the other end of this
very long hallway you could see you
could tell there was lift and she told
me so in a wheelchair we have to go all
the way there and up and then all the
way back to do what we just did in a few
seconds that's not fair and children
have a way of seeing things for what
they are and even though this building
obviously it's very modern and comply
with all the standards it was it was
still a fact that it was not fair so I
like to expand on the previous
definition by saying that beyond no
denying access we need to make sure that
access that we are providing is fair to
all of our users and I'm giving full
credit to my daughter for that quote so
we've covered what accessibility is but
we mentioned the word disability so
let's look at that a little bit more we
are a disability can be split roughly
into these four categories physical
visual hearing and cognitive and while
we may be more familiar with permanent
disabilities we also have temporary and
situational
so those close captions that benefit a
deaf person can also benefit anyone of
us on that spectrum and I like to say us
because each and every one of us spend
some time in our daily lives on that
spectrum so you may have other reasons
for wanting to to watch that breaking
news video without audio and so it's not
an us versus them thing and we all
benefit from accessibility but going
back to permanent disability there's
about 1 billion people in the world the
disabilities it's about 15% of the
population but once you factor in where
in the world your user base is and what
their demographics are you'll get you'll
get a clearer picture a closer number to
what to what that percentage is for your
user base after we did those numbers it
worked out to be 26% around 26%
potentially of our of our user base and
at Ft and you know many other places we
go to great lengths to support all
segments of our audience so if we have
5% of people using IE 8 we kind of try
to make sure that they have some kind of
experience so in this case we had
potentially 26% of people who weren't
getting an experience at all so that
kind of just seeing things in numbers
tends to to motivate people to to get
started with things so let's say I've
convinced you now and you're determined
to do this are you gonna fix
accessibility on your style it's gonna
check you know what it's like and you're
gonna be their very best at it but it
scary and overwhelming and there's a lot
of information out there and it's kind
of hard to know where to start
our suggestion is just start small for
us starting small meant doing this we
installed poly
that's pa-11 why a 11y for accessibility
and tight palace and open source tool
that can check your HTML and
automatically detect some accessibility
errors and report them back to you it
doesn't detect everything but it's a
really good place to start if you have
nothing so the way it works is it goes
through your your markup and it change
it checks it against the web contact
content accessibility guidelines just or
wack
it's a list of criteria that accessible
websites should meet so it checks your
markup against that and it gives you a
report that looks something like that
that's when we ran pally manually
against the telecom it shows two errors
so although the first time we did it had
probably 100 errors and we once we did
this for the first time we could have
gone about manually fixing all of the
error site it found and then running it
again and so on but on such a large code
base like the one we have this wasn't
really efficient so we went for poly CI
which is basically a wrapper around poly
that you can integrate into your
continuous integration process so it
will run automatically every time I'll
show you in a little bit how that
happens there are other tools besides
poly that do this kind of thing but we
found poly just very easy to use very
easy to integrate and they are supported
by a fabulous team of hard-working
individuals that are just always there
with any you know any questions you may
have they're just very supportive and
just continuously working to improve the
tool so our so yeah we went with that
and it's been great so I want to show
you what that looks like in our project
this is a an overlay simplified view of
our of our stack we have several node
apps that make up ft.com so you'll see
the front page have article app signup
page my 50 page those whole node apps
they live in and github deploy them too
we will use circle CI for containers
integration and once we push that gets
triggered and if it's the master branch
it goes live to Heroku
again overly simplified but at least for
them for what we need it
it's enough of a view pally kicks in
thus the continuous integration step so
for every branch that we push this check
happens on the code for that branch and
then you get a report back to integrate
this with our with our existing build
process we only had to add one line and
all that line did was called policy I in
our case since we have we generator and
on the fly app for every branch we have
we just run poly
on that you know also generated up and
and yes so we ran it for every for every
branch we ran it on that on that app and
the interesting bit here is the
threshold argument that you see here so
that will allow pally to run and allow
to find up to 100 errors without
breaking your build which is ideally you
want the build to break if they're silly
even one error but since we had we
couldn't really hold production and say
I'm gonna break all the bills for all
the apps and ft.com can't be updated
until we fix all these because it was a
couple hundred errors so that wasn't
viable that we no one would have let us
do that so we did was have the threshold
argument and all of our bills were still
green so all of our branches were still
passing people were still walking
working this the same way they used to
work but we were getting reports now
like the ones you see here
of what was broken in that branch so we
spent a few weeks we'll put this inside
of all of our all of our apps and maybe
a day because that's it's literally one
night I need to add and then we spent
the next few weeks going through all of
the apps fixing the accessibility issues
that that were found and then for every
app where we reach zero errors we remove
the threshold and now for any new branch
that was created off of that codebase if
it had accessibility errors then it
would break bill so once you remove the
threshold there's no errors allowed so
that once we did this for all of our
apps we got to a place where we were
confident that we were stopping any new
accessibility errors from making it into
production and I was a big deal for us
we felt like you know with which we
reached a really good place so no more
errors no more new accessibility errors
would make it into into the labs live
site but we realized that even though
people were all for ballet they were all
supportive of accessibility they knew
what it was and everyone was really
excited even about having their builds
broken people were looking forward to
their bill being broken so that they
could see what the issue was we didn't
really do a great job of explaining how
those bills would break and more
importantly why you had to do once I
your build was broken so that was lesson
number two that we learned before you
set the build on fire trained people so
how do you go about that so we you could
go about it two ways you can show them
what what they can expect
pollito fine and then what to do about
it and then you can of course do some
training courses we'll talk about both
in a little bit so in terms of what Poli
can find in your project I'm gonna skip
through these fairly quickly because we
don't have too much time but I'm happy
to chat about any of these in the break
or at any other time so one of the most
common issues that Holly found was color
contrast issues when the text doesn't
have enough contrast with the background
that's a big deal we had it everywhere
and another thing was alt text missing
in images alt text is what the like the
name says the alternative if a user
can't see the image of blind users using
a screen reader the old text is the only
thing that will tell them what the image
is and it was missing from from a lot of
our images that was a that was very
common labels and input fields sometimes
they weren't related we would forget to
relate him by the ID and your UI will
look the same but it will break things
completely for some assistive tech so
that was very common as well required
fields that we would mark with an
asterisk and then check with JavaScript
but we never heard had the word required
in some of the in some of the markup and
that's a big deal too so if you feel
required make sure your labor required
ads were also a big problem I can go on
for for a while about this but I won't
in this talk but if you have any
questions if you have ads on your site
and you're worried about what they do to
accessibility we can we can have a chat
after but in short they're they're a big
mess also do having duplicate content on
the site can be an issue and there ways
to mitigate that and one of the ways is
adding some invisible content when you
actually have to have duplicate content
like those are too mighty buttons that
just have to be there
if you add some context that's invisible
that will help people using assistive
tech anyway I'm happy to chat about any
any of these afterwards another thing
that you can do in terms of training
your teams it's doing some accessibility
courses there's a lot of them out there
for free this is a very good one that we
did it's where we got our start it's a
free Udacity course by Alice Boxhall and
Rob Dodson from Google from the
accessibility team I'll share the slides
later so you can grab the URL but it's
really really good
you can do it at your own pace and it
will give you a good introduction and
like solid understanding of the basics
of accessibility so I really recommend
it so we've set the tools tools like
Pali can cover about 20 to 30 percent of
accessibility errors on your site so
this is sort of the first stage of your
journey so you're kind of there and it's
a big deal you've covered a lot and your
site is very likely a lot more
accessible than it was before but
there's a bit more to go before you get
to the summit and which means you need
to make your site fully accessible and
to do that there's some manual
intervention that that needs to happen
so I'm gonna go over that now so this
the the manual side of things can be in
the form of an external audit you can
have a third party check your site like
accessibility experts checking you or
your side and your markup you can do
some customer research ideally putting
your site in front of users with
disabilities that can give you feedback
and then you can learn to use this
assistive technology yourself so you can
sort of getting the shoes of some of
these users these are not mutually
exclusive ideally should be doing them
all so in our case the external audit
was performed by the digital
accessibility Center I'm going to show
you a quick video of the work that they
did it's see if we have audio my name is
Rebecca Morgan I have cyber policy I
test with all situation and cabrona
method choose three click button
the controls with the videos are not
even that big jargon
my name is James okay and I'm the color
contrast and readability analyst at the
digital accessibility Center and today
on the homepage I encountered some text
displayed on top of images text
displayed on top of images can be quite
difficult to read because of the varying
color contrast of the image behind the
text and we see add I'm a website
analyst at the DAC
I test using zoomtext with audible
feedback as the assistive technology i'm
gonna scroll on down hello
and just demonstrate so there's an empty
space here which would be an ideal place
ft to put the subheading name is
jonathan brew I'm a cognitive analyst at
the digital accessibility Center there
is a moving image that distracts me from
all the content another issue I've found
on the homepage is the carousel when
navigating through it I couldn't find
the arrow to to navigate to each page
and once I found that eventually finding
the other previous button was difficult
hello there my name is Mike Jones I'm
completely blind and I'm a screen reader
analyst for the digital accessibility
Center on one of the articles I tested
there are several headings that
announces read more and these also
interrupt the articling it's not clear
what the user will be reading more about
verb etre this these headings actually
interrupt the main article that the user
is reading so it would have been helpful
to me to ensure that the article read
smoothly and continuously without
interruptions so this is only a two
minute video but we we actually were
lucky enough to be able to spend the day
a full day with a with the analysts and
it was I highly recommend it if you have
the chance because it will really change
your perspective forever of how people
use the product that you're building so
that audit that was performed on our
site produced a 200 page report with all
the errors that they found and we
wouldn't spend maybe a couple months
fixing those it was a lot of errors and
in the end we got an official
accreditation that said st tacoma is
accessible to such-and-such level and we
were very very glad to get it obviously
i was months of hard work but it's it's
a title we don't really want to hold
alone so if there anyone is anyone here
from you know other news publications or
really anyone this is really one metric
we should all be trying to outdo each
other on kind the same way we tried to
outdo each other on performance we want
to be faster than the competition but we
want to be more accessible than the
competition we should be we should be
and compete on this we all win if we're
all more accessible so the second thing
is to do customer research get your
product in front of actual users because
you may have all the theory right you
may have your accreditation in place but
you want your new features to be to be
tested by actual users or you might end
up building something that looks good on
paper but still get it very very wrong
and lastly you can learn to use assist
assistive tech yourself this this you
can do for free
and I highly encourage it because it's
also a lot of fun these are some of the
tools that we use on our setup we use
Mac's at the FT so we use voiceover
voiceover keyboard only and we zoom if
you're on a Mac you can get these for
free one thing that really helped was
going keyboard only so initially what we
did was when we were about to test the
side we would just not use the trackpad
and not use the mouse and test it with a
keyboard but it really helps to find the
more nuanced issues if you go keyboard
only all the time so we did that just to
experiment but then we can stay doing
that you know those who have volunteered
to do this
this was my set up back in November last
year when I started doing this so it I
do recommend printing out the shortcuts
for the apps that you most used before
you kind of unplug your mouse and and
turn off your trackpad can be really
helpful so this was mean I said it back
then but as you use this you memorize
the shortcuts even if you don't want to
so I think I'm about almost of that
papers gone I think about how about 10
left that I haven't managed to learn
because I don't use them very often but
but yeah it's really really helpful to
just really really not use the mouse and
the trackpad I just did that by having
an external keyboard with like a numeric
keypad but one if I'm stalking my laptop
and I don't have the external keyboard
and my track that's gonna be active I
try to make it as uncomfortable as
possible to use so I remove all the
goodies that that app will give us make
it very slow so that if I you know start
going back to using the trackpad a lot
I'll notice it's uncomfortable and
remember to go back to the keyboard so
if I if you have the chance to do it I
highly recommend it I'd also make you
faster you become this power user and
you learn to you learn very quickly
which sites are accessible and which
signs aren't
you'll find in github you can navigate
around without a mouse very quickly I
feed on already and you'll find you can
do this in other sites that maybe you
didn't do before
so that's lesson number three that we
learn throw away your mouse
okay so going back to this list of
things that you still have to fix it's
it's you've learned to use all the tools
your setup with your keyboard it's very
tempting to just roll up your sleeves
and try to fix everything yourself but
if we can give you one piece of advice
don't don't do this one thing that I
learned I want to say I learned pretty
quickly but it took me a while to learn
it was that trying to fix all these
things especially on a large site like a
cheetah come it's not really the right
answer you will most definitely burn out
very quickly it's inefficient bugs
New York's ability bugs will happen
faster then you can clean them up and
you really are doing a disservice to
your team by becoming the bottleneck the
person that fixes everything
so most people really want to help and
want to you know get this right if they
just know how to do that so spend some
of your effort not just in fixing the
bugs but in in raising awareness
awareness and training your people on
accessibility yeah instead of just
trying to fix everything yourself and
also if you have a say in your
recruitment process make it a part of it
so this is this was our old requirements
based job description last year but we
added it in there and now it's sort of
you can add it in there at the bottom
just sneak it into the desired skills
and it can work its way up and also if
you have an online test or some kind of
coding test at some point make sure you
include an accessibility question in
there and I apologize for redacting some
of these because we're actively hiring
and I don't want to give too much away
but the idea is that you know you have a
some markup and you asked how would you
make this more accessible so you can
engage you know if people have had
exposure to accessibility or at least if
there's interest because if you spend
time training your team ideally you want
to if you want to bring more people in
into your team ideally they will have
some knowledge of accessibility or if
not at least think that it's something
that's important to to build into a
project anyway so if you have a saying
in your in your hiring process just
sneak it in there so yeah lesson number
four that we learned kind of the hard
way don't take this all on yourself the
bulk of the work really
taken care of if everyone's a part of it
so and even beyond developers designers
developers QA product we all have a role
to play in making our product accessible
another good way to spread the word is
making an event out of it if you have a
chance
back in November last year we put
together a roadshow in like an open
space that we have at the office we
invited everyone to fill out a look at
perform using a screen reader it's kind
of the software that if you're blind
you're likely to use to navigate
websites it will read out the screen to
you and we offered a free 20 pound
Amazon gift card and turns out people
like free stuff so they showed up so we
had a big crowd and this is the form
that they had to complete and as you can
see or cannot see you can't see very
much you were forced to rely on the
screen reader to tell you what's on the
screen so and a lot of people who
stopped by had never used a screen
reader before didn't know what it was
and some of them didn't even know about
the concept of accessibility so this was
a good way to getting a lot of people
exposed to to all this this is a forum
it's a very simple form that was built
to be accessible so you could fill it
out using a screen reader and it was we
did this for a couple hours in this open
area and the big takeaway from this this
experiment it's one of the highlights of
my career in the 15 years so that I've
been doing software engineering it's
moments like this one that's if you know
him that's Patrick Hammond he's a
seasoned developer who's really you know
surprised by by web stuff but this was
his reaction to using a screen reader to
use the thing that he built for a living
so and we got that kind of reaction from
a lot of people so it's we managed to
create this space of collective empathy
where we had a couple dozen people's
sort of step into someone else's shoes
for a little bit and they were all
walked away with the knowledge that
they're the product that they build it's
not only used in the way that they use
it a lot of people use it in many
different ways so it's it was very
powerful in sending message
and very effective and raising awareness
so I was lesson number five talked about
it a lot
spread the word make it your thing you
never know who's listening and you're
probably reaching more people than you
think by just talking about it in the
office or at meetups or events like this
so we've said that you know these are
some ways to help make your site more
accessible but obviously these two at
the top cost money so it doesn't mean
that you can't make your product
accessible if you don't have the budget
for it but if you can it's it helps you
reach that that some it helps you reach
higher so there may be times when you
need to raise cash internally or
externally to fund your accessibility
efforts if you need to dedicate one or
two people or some of your time to
accessibility you may need to raise some
money and we needed to do this at the FT
to fund to fund our team and me being
new to this and kind of naive say okay
well accessibility is can it's the right
thing to do it's you know give me give
me some cash and we learned this one we
learned very quickly it's the right
thing to do doesn't really get you a
budget so you need to kind of make a
case for it and Alex Bartlett who works
with us at the origami team put this
together a while ago she's done a lot of
research on sort of the business case
for accessibility how do you sell it to
the business and she found that avoiding
litigation avoiding being sued is one of
the most evidence business cases for
accessibility so if you're a big enough
company you risk getting sued and the
cost when getting sued if your site is
not accessible and the cost of that
lawsuit and the sort of the the brand
damage is a lot higher than what you
could invest in a small team to you know
fix stuff and get things up to speed so
there's a link to I'll share these
slides later so you can grab that link
it's a very good presentation and yeah
you have a lot of information if you
need to make this case yourself in your
company so before we finish I want to
take you back to how this all started
for us at the FT I was in bug Duty one
day and I saw this card in JIRA that
said integrate poly I didn't know what
poly was had no idea it was my
turn about dude I just grabbed it and I
got a little bit curious and I looked
through the history of the cart and I
saw that he had been bouncing around our
board for months and it was only until
my colleague Ben Fletcher who was a
senior developer at the time and who
happens to be deaf blind he prioritized
it and he just made us all whether this
is something that maybe we should be
working on and this is the last lesson
that I want to leave you with diversity
will improve your product will improve
your team and will improve your life
this Ben's small action on that JIRA
boards snowballed into us building a
better product the team learning about
accessibility and that to me standing in
front of you're here today
so to recap and to give you things that
you could do tonight in under half an
hour accessibility doesn't just happen
you have to do something about it one
good way to start is integrate piling
into your process give it a high
threshold just let it run and start
getting reports of what's broken with
what you're building if anything train
your people so you can something you can
do very quickly share that link to that
Udacity course and may people do it on
their own time so there's some awareness
of what accessibility is and why it
matters throw away your mouse you can do
that very quickly but ideally print out
shortcuts beforehand don't take it all
on yourself
share share the load the more people
around you who know about it the easier
it will be and the more efficient you'll
be talk about it
Twitter put up together Roadshow if you
can in terms of budget if you have to
raise one I remember the the biggest
motivator is avoiding getting sued and
getting sued is expensive and
embarrassing and we don't want that it's
probably cheaper to just invest in
accessibility and diversity matters and
I wish I had something I could give you
that you could do in a couple minutes
tonight but for this one I don't but if
you have a say in hiring or in any of
these areas and where you work try and
prioritize in the the most more diverse
that you have in your team the better
the thing that you build on the burial
life will be lastly a while back having
this PD
only entrance to a public building
wasn't a norm there was nothing wrong
with it
but now would be unthinkable right to
have you know only stairs be the only
way you can get into a public building
so we're a little bit behind on software
so don't wait until it becomes
unthinkable for to build inaccessible
websites the the time to make to start
making your website accessible is really
now so just do it thank you very much
[Applause]